tiens secondes et je l'informé bien
dedans puis rien de bien vivre à temps
en temps mais l'horizon
parce que probert de l'horizon c'est
qu'elle était trop loin je garde c'est
vachement beau la gauche était à gauche
qui roule je suis un frontal et j'allais
revenir vers la droite par la brillance
à gauche à gauche à gauche la grosse
poussée c'est un poteau du vert partout
tout ça c'est vachement jolie oui il
stipulé cheville ce titre il arrête de
bouger tant lieux du tournage est une
foule interloquée gracia tic
mais cela c'est très beau l'aller tout
est petit il me manquait pas ce bassin
d'environ ya pas beaucoup on verra pas
du coup on part on verra pas les trois
animaux les petits passages ne pas vous
faire mal et chérir et pas beaucoup
d'oiseaux donc le jeu fait à travailler
une chaise du filet et c'est le
président guy dans un peu là non toi tu
arrêtais tour baisse était bon et il
avait parfois une touche tout beau tout
fait comme cherche le point est un
élément de ce plan les suivants verront
là un enjeu ce faire on les suit or
monsieur hockey petit polo devions y en
ad'autres deux oiseaux toi c'est
beaucoup plus goût à gauche regarde à
gauche voire regarde la regardent le
petit petit arbre guitare gbagbo tu le
vois tu forêt à gauche la voie la bouche
plusieurs bazars de ciment partir en
courant la chance aux lions sans von
haller atteint le web chinois par besson
il sera devant toi rails sont là par
leurs auteurs ok aux policiers que ça
regarde un peu plus large ou à raison
howard schultz d'accompagner safetic est
du lac regarde pas de paysages
par contre 3000 oiseaux